one small college town is taking a
collective sigh of relief another is now
in the spotlight for its connection to
an alleged serial killer Brian coburger
is accused of stabbing four University
of Idaho students to death inside of
their off-campus home coburger was on
the path toward a doctorate at nearby
Washington State University and students
in Pullman Washington began their spring
semester on Monday in fact many told
reporters that they had never felt
unsafe in their in their town before now
professors took part in trauma workshops
to prepare for any stress that students
might be dealing with people who live
and work a few miles away in Moscow
Idaho say that they're proud of their
Police Department's response to the to
the rare crime
well I think they got a lot of flack for
uh keeping their cards tight to their
chest which I always felt like that's
what they were doing and um so I was
pretty elated when
the when they caught this guy and um all
this evidence was revealed and I felt
like they needed to be thanked it's been
a big deal I mean I'm a little emotional
to talk about it I'm
you know the students here are family to
us they're our customers they're our
friends and um it was such a tragic
horrible thing that happened that it
affected us all very deeply as for
coburger his defense team is expected
back in court for a status hearing on
Thursday after seeing the apparent
mountain of evidence against coburger
and the probable cause affidavit we
asked celebrity defense attorney Alan
dershowitz how would he handle a case
like this
every case is different and every
defense is different I am always opposed
to lawyers who say I always do it this
way I always put the client on the stand
I never put the client on the stand
remember too the affidavit only presents
one side of the story uh it's only the
prosecution's version you have to begin
to develop your own evidence and I'm
going to surprise people when I say that
a good criminal defense lawyer always
starts with a presumption of guilt not a
presumption of innocence you always
assume your client is guilty and then
you work back from there if you assume
your client is innocent you'll make
mistakes you'll allow searches you'll
allow him to speak to the police so you
always start with a presumption of guilt
and then try to develop evidence that
questions or challenges
Brian you're the resident defense
attorney you agree with Mr dershowitz
would you have a similar game plan
presumption of guilt I guess according
to dershowitz I'm not a good defense
attorney every defense attorney does it
differently I don't buy into that I
think I maybe do something a little
similar I go with the presumption of
innocence but the prosecution's case is
the strongest thing against him and I
think if you look at it that way we're
saying hey I believe my guy is innocent
and I'm just talking about cases where I
know I got to go to trial I'm not
talking about negotiating please but if
it's a trial case I go with the
Assumption of my client is Innocent but
the prosecution has the strongest case
in the world if you're going with that
mindset you fight a little bit harder to
try to disprove their case of course if
you can't disprove their case then
you're looking to try to negotiate but
in a case like this if you presume that
your client is guilty I don't think
they're going to be working as hard but
I understand what he's saying you got to
really attack the prosecution's case
thinking that it is stronger than
anything else that you can see
so Terry let's assume the worst for
Coburg let's say his defense strategy
loses it doesn't work the jury then is
going to maybe have to decide the issue
of the death penalty if it's pursued by
prosecutors you think a jury would
impose the death penalty in this kind of
case you know that's a really tough
question we know that the prosecution
has asked for the death penalty but that
doesn't mean that they're going to have
a jury that's going to actually execute
on that so basically you're going to
have to make sure you are selecting
jurors who don't have any sort of
opposition to the death penalty and it
obviously has to be unanimous they're
going to go through aggravating
circumstances they're going to go
through mitigating circumstances and try
to determine whether or not one
outweighs the other and if you get just
one juror who doesn't agree you're not
going to get the death penalty and we've
seen this again I'm mentioning the
Parkland shooter case we absolutely
thought many people thought that that
was going to be a death penalty case and
at the end of the day the jury didn't
have a unanimous decision as far as that
was concerned so we got life in prison
there and something like that could
happen here even if there is a
conviction it's a heinous crime but
there's no guarantee that an entire jury
is going to agree to that yeah you can
somehow sometimes predict you know how a
jury is going to weigh in terms of guilt
or not guilty but death penalty I agree
with you sometimes so unpredictable
Brian Terry thanks so much great work
we're going to see you next time
everybody as we discuss Justice in
America